c'est la quatrième fois qu'ils se
rencontrent et entendre louis boutrin
vice-président de martinique transport
peut être la dernière
la bonne nouvelle c'est que les acteurs
semblent d'accord sur la reprise de tous
les salariés avec leurs acquis la
mauvaise c'est que les négociations
achoppent encore sur un point qui
réclame ray un engagement impossible à
tenir selon martin transports le point
de désaccord c'est la proposition qui a
été faite d'avoir un employeur unique
nous avons pu démontrer que c'était
contraire aux dispositions actuelles du
code des marchés publics puisque depuis
2016 il ya une obligation d'un
lotissement des marchés publics de
manière à ce qu'on puisse garantir la
libre concurrence notamment pour les
petits opérateurs les petites
entreprises
l'intersyndicale a donc fait une autre
proposition qui viserait à instaurer une
unité économique et sociale du futur
repreneur
une proposition que louis boutrin
acceptent de soumettre au prochain
conseil d'administration de martinique
transport mi janvier et encore avec une
condition préalable
c'est la quatrième réunion à la demande
du préfet et des organisations
syndicales
nous avons fixé un préalable c'est qu'il
est la reprise du service public de
transport sur le territoire
la cacem reprise sans délai parce que
les usagers personne ne défend le droit
des usagers
sans véritable surprise l'intersyndicale
de la cft u qui n'a pas souhaité
s'exprimer à notre micro maintient son
mouvement de grève la situation demeure
donc au point mort